[Music]
we live with risk every day we assess
risk we assess that that 155 million is
low risk and is not affecting our
preparedness whatsoever for Dorian I'm
really disappointed that President Trump
has proposed taking money from FEMA for
walls or cages or militarization of the
border any potential transfers will not
impact our ability to respond to this
storm or any other storms and the rest
of the hurricane season so there's some
of that back and forth after the
administration decided to take some FEMA
disaster relief money and help secure
the border with that let's bring in our
panel Jeff Mason White House
correspondent for Reuters Molly
Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist and Susan freaky Oh chief
congressional correspondent for the
Washington Examiner Susan let's start
with you big deal to shift this money
it's really a drop in the bucket when it
comes to disaster relief funding there's
several billion dollars in that fund so
this is just a tiny amount FEMA is also
already allocated it supplies to
disaster relief centers for the season
so all that is already taken care of
this isn't going to unless you know say
the hurricane curves in and causes some
kind of unimaginable catastrophe that's
so far not forecast it's just really no
way that this is going to impact their
operations right now Molly it's also
important that people focus on what's
happening at the state level frequently
when you have disasters of this nature
what's happening at the state level has
more to do with the success of a group
of people making it through the storm to
that end Florida really should be
commended for and I know they have a lot
of experience handling this but reports
coming out of there show such a great
work on communication preparing planning
and hopefully that will continue if by
chance the response is slow Jeff Jeff
this would be something they will point
at their critics at least about shifting
this money right sure I mean there's so
much in of what happens in Washington is
about optics this is not a great optic
and it's one that Democrats are seizing
on and for sure if the response ends up
not being as good as they've said it
could be or would be then I imagine the
Democrats would would focus on that more
okay topic number two
shooting in Odessa Texas over the
weekend full disclosure my first
reporting job was in Midland Odessa
Texas on my hearts go out to those good
folks there take a listen to this I've
been speaking to a lot of senators we've
been speaking to a lot of House members
a lot of Republicans a lot of Democrats
and people want to do something so we're
going to see this really hasn't changed
anything we're doing a package and we'll
see what it all how it comes about it's
happy talk and this promise that we're
gonna do something we're gonna look at
it but they never actually do it Susan
what are you hearing from your sources
on the hill in terms of discussions
about some kind of legislative package
yeah there is some enthusiasm to try to
put something together you're heard
Mitch McConnell say earlier in August
that we're going to focus on some kind
of background check legislation
potentially red flag laws so all eyes
really will be on the Senate because if
you can find a compromise there because
that would be bipartisan because of the
filibuster rule that might lead the way
in terms of what Congress can get done
however it's going to require
cooperation not just from Democrats and
that in the Senate but in the house
where they tend to be more progressive
and they may push for far more liberal
gun controls kind of measures than they
might want to see in the Senate so it's
gonna be a real uphill climb but I think
the action won't first focus on the
Senate Molly are there some common-sense
things they can do what about mental
health also violent video games and
anything that both sides can agree on
this is one of the problems I think with
these immediate reactions to these
horrible instances of murder is people
just want to do something and they want
to do something even if it would do
nothing to prevent such tragedies
unfortunately even as you see other
issues of violence on decline or serial
murders on decline mass shootings are
increasing and it's a very complicated
thing as to why everything from you know
the everything from the presence of guns
to mental health issues even how the
media cover it and I think this is
something that without in without in any
way restricting First Amendment freedoms
in at all the media need to think about
whether they are helping create
something of a social contagion with
some of these things and think about how
to cover them
Geof administration officials believe
they're going to get something done
well basically they say they do and and
they are working on something whether or
not that something ends up being as
advanced or as as strong as a lot of
progressive Democrats are hoping for is
is an open question I think the other
open question is what do they actually
do on background checks the president
has wavered a little bit on how strongly
he'd like to see advanced and broader
background checks brought in under
pressure from the NRA but there's
certainly pressure from the other side
the Democrats and progressives to do
more there so you have preparations for
a massive hurricane you have a terrible
mass shooting in Texas and then you've
got new measures going into place
yesterday related to China on trade
issues take a listen to this and I'll
get you guys to weigh in we are talking
to China the meeting is still on as you
know in September we'll see what happens
but we can't allow China to rip us off
anymore is the country so while this may
not be a Republican orthodoxy there are
a lot of people on both sides who say we
should not allow China to be ripping the
United States off well Trump is in this
rare occurrence here where people really
do support him on both sides of the
aisle on China he's got Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer very vocally supporting
him on this issue saying don't give up
don't relent and part of the reason is
that China's unfair trade practices have
you know led to 50 billion a year in
intellectual property theft I think the
trade deficit was somewhere around 400
billion in 2018 so it's a huge problem
and it's getting worse every year and
now the president says I'm going to
tackle it and I'm not gonna back down
it's causing a lot of strain and
problems here in the United States but I
think economists agree that ultimately
China is the one who suffers most from
this trade war so there's the running
theory that they are going to Bend first
but so far they're not I think a lot of
Republicans on the ballot next year and
the president's allies are worried about
an economic impact
malee your thoughts on this they're
right to be worried about economic
impacts you conduct trade wars like this
when you are in a healthy economic
situation and so it's the right time to
do it but it does come at a pretty
serious cost and China wants to it seems
like wait out to this presidency
I think people need to start thinking
through though just how different the
situation is from other situations we've
had when we were in a cold war with the
Soviet Union we didn't see high levels
of trade there there was a general
understanding that working with the
communists did not mean that we would
trade with them as China which is a
communist country controlled by the
Communist Party they run their military
they run their economy they might see
that the US and other countries aren't
as interested in working with them that
India for whatever else its faults are
is a functioning democracy that can
handle factories and and you might see
some kind of transition here might be a
complete reordering of things in a
separation of these economies Jeff
briefly do your sources think they'll
get a deal well I don't think there's
gonna be a deal anytime soon from my
sources the big question right now and
the short term is when will they hold
talks again that both sides have said
they want to meet in September but they
haven't come up with a date and we're in
September September yes panel thank you
very much